[Music]
in dirty cop news oh why did you take a
shower submitted by not one foo ok a
sheriff deputy has been arrested for
allegedly assisting a felon in drug
trafficking dirty cop inception Utz
inception and what was the other one
when the gangster is a cop and the cop
is the gangster oh you're talking about
[Laughter]
Infernal Affairs no it's a I like it a
lot too it's just I've just been thing
anybody would say that a great movie
noodle show you Rami
[Laughter]
this story's kind of interesting it was
a six month investigation in Indiana and
it led to the arrest of 20 people and it
unveiled like a family drug ring oh god
man I can't go to jail I cannot do it at
least it's a family business
I'm just trying to be positive here I
think gels do boring for me jail yeah
you know what it is about jail to you
know the [ __ ] that they [ __ ] like
trying to sneak in and they create is
none of the stuff I want cigarettes you
know ROM annual ramen I don't like
American ramen I want an Xbox how you
guys squeezing an xbox for me I can't
taste her that yeah you don't know you
got to go to like those federal prisons
but you get to fight get specials that's
okay I'm gonna get my ass beat yeah so
uh you should speed it the gay you
should be the gays in there just like as
long as they don't try to like [ __ ] me
that I'll kick it with them I know how
you could you just make everybody laugh
and be like dude I'll hook you up with
some bomb-ass ramen oh I could be the
chef I'll cook you I'll cook you some
[ __ ] I'll make some dope ass you just
don't [ __ ] me everybody loves to [ __ ]
well now don't [ __ ] with me just don't
don't [ __ ] me please but if you [ __ ] me
in the ass you ain't getting that ramen
boy I wonder if inmates come out and
they eat regular food and they get
diarrhea broccoli [ __ ] like they're so
used to that prison food that they come
on there's like all this extra grease
they get crazy diarrhea
so you're saying prisons too boring for
you because you love violence but
prisons all about violence no but most
of the time we're just like in the cage
and this is you and your bunkmate and
you guys so you arm wrestle for an hour
and you tell each other [ __ ] life
stories for an hour but [ __ ] each other
for our what else you gotta do I mean
don't don't they have like assigned
chores for you guys to do like laundry
or like clean something that's is boring
only we do tour that office Troy why
would you want to do it like chef's
laundry ob the kitchen yeah I hate
cooking but I'd be in the kitchen dude I
don't know it's kind of like living in a
dorm without having to do homework yeah
you just hang out with your friends all
day just I hear that the worst thing is
that you get no peace and quiet that's
like the worst oh yeah
quiet moment where you just taking a nap
there's a story that one prisoner who
like one day it was snowing outside and
he just kind of went outside to do so I
don't know he was like running and doing
something maybe by angels
he don't look a bit a little dish so
that the wind just go over him and he
slept he was like that was the most best
sleep I've had in years cuz it was
outside to let him just be out there I
don't know you supposed to do I don't
know I don't know why it was outside but
he's like this is the only like this is
the one thing that I love the most cuz I
finally had some peace and quiet because
you don't have quiet to think in there
dude
you're surrounded by people with no
walls so they shut off noise I think I
like travelling too much to go to jail
yeah so anyways so this story the deputy
the sheriff's deputy his name's Jerry
Parks 37 years old so what the police
chief is saying like he he thinks that
he's the uncle of this man named Danny
who's 33 and so apparently Jerry the cop
was giving Danny
undercover narcotics information like
they're gonna raid narcotics officers
information like right information and
telling him how the cops go about doing
like you know researching or how the
cops go about investigating the whole
drug ring thing and also he gave him a
[ __ ] loaded gun where the [ __ ] did
you find a gun to kill but no one he
says he's a deputy a sheriff's deputy
but then there's always all guns are
assigned in some way maybe then what's
like the evidence room or something
oh yeah we still gotta sign into those
oh is it gold so the authorities are
also alleging that the deputy held drugs
belonging to Danny for safekeeping and
of Stoli a boyfriend yeah and so when he
gave him a deputy issued service weapon
oh [ __ ] for protection while
transporting money that was raised
through drug deals he was also doing
that and and then they're also saying
that the deputy gave Danny narcotics
that the deputy had seized while
performing his duties as a sheriff's
deputy
so thank you he was like the cops the
mastermind and he's just giving all the
tools for his nephew to like execute
yeah here's a good here's the drugs to
sell it this is where the cops this is
their routine you can bypass it by doing
this how much money they make off this
[ __ ] ah they don't mention how much
money they make if it was like fifty
thousand dollars worth waste yeah you
know but it was like half a million or
something well this was a six-month
investigation that was going on that
found all this out sewn prettier than me
that wonder was like what the endgame is
for the cop like do you think he just
stopped and then no one just ever gonna
wonder ever again or is he gonna leave
or like what feel like you thought you
could get away with it or something cuz
his wife was in it too was also arrested
damn chased down huh bad [ __ ] you got I
know I ran your breaking bad deputy and
this is the nephew they look we're later
they both look like criminals yeah and
then this is the wife but in total I was
20 people and I'm so sad she's rolling
her eyes interesting she can't do that
because I think to myself like what I
survive in prison if I get caught no so
I'm just not even gonna bother yes I've
been we have friends
like a reunion I always I always in
prison I always figure like everyone
gets caught eventually you know what if
we're all in prison would you want to
join us you know [ __ ] you guys I like my
fried chicken and food out here no foods
too delicious outside yeah it's not
where you at it's who you're with
everybody knows that that's where you're
at it's cool your win I'll come visit
you guys through the glass the food is
bomb out here that's all you say to us
are you like a packet of hot sauce or
something this board is gonna want a
mess great out here
nice mob to me the best food ever we
shouldn't come with freedom is something
that's so overlooked it is a blessing to
be free my friends do whatever [ __ ] you
know I'm waving the American flag in
it's nice to be free today man it's
[ __ ] fantastic dude that's why even
like I think I like that's why like
artistry
there's even freedom in your work
freedom is something I really really
really enjoy so let's talk about me
whooping somebody that's not gonna
happen
touch my shoulder you'd be down to go to
prison if we all went to prison no I'll
break you out there's no like Chinese
hard wooden pillows for you Joe Joe if
you have a plan to break out of jail or
prison I would be down if I'm in jail
yeah no no she's outside that's so
tiring you break me out well you would
break him out either way if you have a
plan I'm done I think it's more like I'm
so lazy you know like it's so tiring I
first of all have to wake up in another
night to break out and then it's
physical activity and I a spend the rest
of my life running and hiding I could
never just relax
but jail is perfect for lazy people you
don't have to meet our responsibilities
I'm lazy but I'm also I also get bored
but it's like girls night out every
night what's your tonight my stripes how
about you my oranges do each other's
hair
what's a sleepover every night I know -
the violence it would be like that and
then I gotta act like I'm a lot tougher
than I actually am and I don't like just
soften me yeah I mean then we all know
the first thing in person what happens
the guy would the biggest tisket
titty-fuck they try to be a delectable
dish my [ __ ] man I like being ejected
fide and it's like he's a cop - so he he
knows what goes on in prison and he
still wants to do this [ __ ] like he's
[ __ ] he's dead I would love to sell
drugs though I would love to sell drugs
if one I didn't get hurt into it and get
caught see that's the only two things
but a half-wit crook is pretty cool yeah
being a halfway cross that that's like a
bad lawyer kinda you're kind of yeah
you're kinda legal but you're not
committed to be that illegal okay that's
just never get the biggest gains being a
halfway crook though I know it's more
like maybe like you're a what is it
you're you're like the kind of lawyer
that would be really tough talk off the
record on your personal phone it's all
like that I think I want to like if
you're a wannabe gangster you could
dress and act and look the part and then
maybe like people like you because they
think you're somebody but in a real life
you don't have to do the crime I like
that [ __ ] that's that's the cool part I
be Gus fring why is crazy and he's not
afraid to go to jail and I don't know
what his family looks like I was waiting
to see his wife in kid I never saw them
I know that kind of buddies yeah that
was kind of weird yeah yeah he's suppose
he's a family man really yeah I don't
know I just want to be as smart as Gus
fring and terrifying that was a [ __ ]
love [ __ ] Hector Salamanca this
[ __ ] had a twisted lippisch face
to the face you know you know when he's
angry like he's sucking on a lollipop
Lourdes Hector do you still won't look
at me
he's got how you want to go out like uh
boom walked outside oh man y'all have
you ever seen Breaking Bad that their
season third season for season
I remember the report point Caesar yeah
the fourth season the best season ever
yeah I've never been so emotionally
invested like to the point where I'm
screaming at the TV I've never done that
in my life every season every episode
Game of Thrones I'm screaming at the TV
hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
with you all right other than that you
know there's like more videos up there
bro
[Music]